today in England witchcraft and is more
modern incarnation Wicca our pagan
religions
Wiccans worship the gods and spirits of
nature in return for their faith
the spirits grant them the power of
magic it was this power that first drew
Daley's Cod to Wicca now she's studying
to become a full-fledged witch I like
the name witch and I suppose anywhere
I'd like to reclaim it as being a good
word and a standing for all the things
that I believe in she has her husband's
complete support though he has no
interest in witchcraft himself
she knows others will not be so
accepting I'm very careful about who I
tell I'm very careful about he sees my
pentacle comparators that sits by me and
I have a great belief that it should be
next to my my body as opposed to on show
so there's a lot of prejudice still once
a month
Kaylee's meets with her coven a group of
like-minded witches who bolster one
another in their faith they call
themselves the Raven and the Rose
when witches gather in a circle they
believe they can weave stronger magic
appropriation festival tonight will be
gay Lisa's first time participating in a
secret ritual red sandalwood for passion
it's April 30th tomorrow which is all
over England celebrate what they call
the first day of summer Beltane as High
Priestess of the Raven and the Rose
Jeanette Ellis will lead her covens
Beltane rituals we're cooking up an
incense for Beltane making an incense as
a spell the different ingredients that
go into it like making a cake you blend
them all together and they all have
specific jobs within the cake or the
incense in this case and we'll burn that
tonight on Beltane the coven will thank
the guards for the Earth's renewed
fertility for witches only Halloween All
Hallows Eve is more safe we take the
energy of the goddess and God of Earth
and air and fire and water the energies
of the universe my place within we your
web of dark and light aah air fire and
water
find us or one let nothing impure enter
here in let no one be present unless
they come with an open heart their
rituals shows appreciation for the
return of summer and renewal homage paid
the witches can ask for their gifts from
the gods wisdom
look then as with Holy Day celebrations
everywhere it's time for the party to
begin
for most in England Beltane is known as
mayday an ancient feast still celebrated
widely despite the fears their faith
still sparks which is figure in May Day
festivals across England the Raven and
the Rose coven seizes the opportunity to
march proudly through the streets their
public walk shows that prejudice is
beginning to wane and reminds on lookers
that the celebration of the earth the
sky and the seasons is humankind's
oldest faith